las consecuencias humanitarias y la
violencia se intensifican de manera
preocupante en colombia' es la última
alerta del comité internacional de la
cruz roja tras un balance de los
primeros seis meses de 2022
destaca el aumento de un 43% de las
víctimas de artefactos explosivos el
desplazamiento de 70.000 personas y el
confinamiento de otras 19 mil esos
indicadores de consecuencias
humanitarias muestran la difícil
realidad que enfrentan muchas
comunidades en diversos territorios del
país aún así no logran reflejar de
manera completa el temor la zozobra de
desesperanza que producen los conflictos
armados y la violencia en colombia
en la mira de la actualidad el plan
pistola del clan del golfo también auto
denominadas autodefensas gaitanistas de
colombia este grupo armado ilegal habría
matado a más de 30 policías en 2022 la
última ha sido la semana más violenta
para los uniformados en 5 años el
director de la policía nacional el
general jorge luís vargas envió un
mensaje a los colombianos le pido a
todos mis compatriotas
como policía que robe a su policía
nacional
se movilicen en las redes sociales en
las calles apoyando a los policías de
colombia el clan del golfo busca
mostrarse fuerte tras la extradición
este año de su líder alias otoniel y
también igual que otros grupos se erigen
como una estructura unificada de cada
una negociación con el nuevo gobierno de
gustavo petro que ha prometido la
búsqueda de la paz total
justo
[Aplausos]